حين قرعت روسيا طبول الحرب يظن كثيرون
تماما كما خططت موسكو ان كيف ستسقط خلال
الساعات والايام الاولى لكن سرعان ما
تبدلت الاراء بدا ان الروس يقدمون اداء
ضعيفا وسيئا للغايه فيما ابهر الاوكران
العالم بصمودهم يقول دانيال
سابق في الجيش الامريكي ومؤلف كتاب الساعه
الحاديه عشره في امريكا ان البندول في
ساحه المعركه قد تغير الحرب تسير وفقا
للطريقه الروسيه الان لكن كيف ومتى جرى
التحول
طوال عام 2022 خصصت موسكو قوه عسكريه اقل
من المطلوب لاداء المهمه وقيمت مستويات
الاستراتيجيه والعملياتيه والتكتيكيه
للخطه الاوليه عند الحد الادنى كان واضحا
ان الامدادات العسكريه لم تكن مجهزه
لاستمرار حرب طويله الانسحاب من خاركيف
وكيف بعد شهر كان دليلا كافيا على ذلك
في ابريل اخذت روسيا قرارا استراتيجيا
باعاده نشر قواتها وتعزيزهم على جبهه
دومباس لكنها ظلت تمنى بخسائر موجعه
كالقضاء على كتيبه كامله اثناء عبور نهر
سفر اسكي التكتيك ضمين لروسيا السيطره على
ماريوبل ولمان وبوباسنا
لم يحميها من هجومين اوكرانيين ناجحين
الاول فاجاهم وكلفهم لمان في مقاطعه خرسون
والثاني افقدهم جبهه خاركي في الشماليه
بعد التقهقر واجهت روسيا معضله خوض معارك
دفاعيه دمويه او الاستسلام بحلول اكتوبر
انتصر الخيار الثاني وفي مراهن الغرب على
فشل التكتيك الروسي كانت روسيا تستعد
لتثبت انها جديره بتحمل خسائر بشريه
وعسكريه اكبر وانها تعلمت من اخطائها
بشكل تدريجي بدات اوكرانيا تسجل خسائر في
سيفرودونيسك
التخلي عنك
بدا يؤتي ثماره بعكس مدينه باخمت التي رفض
الاوكران التخلي عنها فدفعوا فاتوره
كلفتهم عشرات الاف القتلى والجرحى واطنانا
من المعدات والذخيره والاهم ان المدينه
خسرت نفسها في النهايه
في هذه المعركه خسر الاوكران مواقع قتاليه
استراتيجيه وطرق امداد مهمه وكسب الروس
ثقتهم باعاده ترتيب اوراقهم واثبات ان
خبرتهم ونفسهم طويل في الحروب
كرم حناوي العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات